pour vous faire une interview monologues
et l'opg lui qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous vous regardez dans un
miroir le temps passe vite
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
j'espère que ça va continuer qu'est ce
que vous dites quand vous vous rasez
sa blanchi tout ça
qu'est ce que vous dites qu'on venait
sur un plateau télé comme ce soir
c'est chez thierry ça va ouais qu'est ce
que vous vous dites quand on vous
reconnaît pas dans la rue
je suis plus dans ma rue
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous êtes
seul le soir chez vous
mais qu'est ce qu'elle fout
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
pensez à votre parcours
il ya de la cohérence ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous êtes
énervé
ah [ __ ] de bordel de merde
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous avez
envie d'abandonner le métier et ben non
ils sont ils sont pas tous comme à la
comédie française ouais qu'est ce que
vous dites quand vous regarder le
journal télévisé de soir en ce moment je
me dis que les gens connaissent pas leur
histoire et non pas beaucoup de mémoire
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
finissez par voir arriver sonia un peu
tard mais elle vient quand même
victoria abril donc là c'est vous avec
vous même hein qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous venez sur un plateau de
télé il faut y aller ouais ouais c'est
dur non non non qu'est ce que vous vous
dites quand vous vous levez le matin
un corps une belle journée
mais surtout il fait gris
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous vous
entendez parler français
qu'est ce que vous dites quand on vous
reconnaît pas dans la rue
des rondes et pottas non
non non et j'ai connu la gloire à 14 ans
à 22 ans je ne pouvais plus c'est pour
ça que je suis venu en france dont et
quand on est con n'est pas dans la rue
ça veut dire que j'ai peu un corps et
voix hier c'est ça qui me plaît
coquine c'est là qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous vous regardez dans un
miroir
j'étais gier mais heureusement que des
puits à non un truc comme ça je vois
plus bien sa lunette
vers la fin il était au top et tout ça
tu as bien prévu les choses parce que
vous enviez mons voit on se voit pas ce
qu'il voit là j'ai bien joué mais on a
des problèmes tu vas insidieux vernis
s'écaille tue les prêts ce qui n'est pas
du voyage
avec moi vous êtes coiffer la par
exemple non je veux non je plaisante est
très jeune mais ici c'est ici que mon
coiffeur j'étais bien ce que je suis
sorti il avait tout qu'est ce que vous
vous dites quand vous retrouvez seul le
soir je ne trouve pas c'est les soldes
et puis quoi encore qu'est ce que vous
dites que vous avez envie d'abandonner
ce métier
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
regarder le journal télévisé
encore
un quart qu'est ce que vous dites qu'on
vous jouez à poil
anglais ventre
d'ailleurs les attentions
je fais des fétus maintenant donc il
faut tout rentre
et bien traités a dit allez il faut les
coller et tout le reste s'ils perdent
restée détendue
comme guy qui conquit qu'ont donc tout
ça bien dure elle avec des départs du
titre non mais je sais je connais cette
technique que la connaît c'est
magnifique il ya que ça qui est bien un
bois dur sur le web c'est très bien
c'est très banal voilà ok qu'est ce que
vous vous dites que je dois passer un
garçon de cinéma et qu'est ce que vous
dites qu'on vous embrasser un garçon
ocldi
elle a très bien répondu non
et je dis à sa maquilleuse de les donner
un chewing gum
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous
embrasser une fille cinéma quand j'avais
est pareil en chine où la mienne
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous n'avez
pas confiance en vous elle pointe
chewing gum et non respect d'âge on
respire on respire et tout ça c'est du
mirage garde présent il n'y a aucune
raison que ça marche pas cette fois ci
tu ne respires à trois fois c'est juste
un mirage il ya aucune raison ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous êtes
prête à tout casser
respire aussi parce que c'est beaucoup
mieux de pas là bas n'est pas tout
casser quand vous touchez la drogue
qu'est ce que vous direz ce pays en tout
six attaquants plus plus la drogue
d'ailleurs il a arrêté de fumer régal
c'est bien ça j'ai arrêté de fumer
regarde
très bien cette nouvelle façon d'habiter
il ya des petits trucs dans une petit
truc gémit des petits boulots doit donc
2 à marcher
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous voyez
un mec canon canon que tu veux dire quoi
canon mécano à camoël à brienon pressé
on était quand même une semaine à tort
mais je vais perdre pied pendant la
grande guerre lasse
et voyez souvent tu te vois souvent tu
en profites d'élèves se sont battus
proches qui a bien ce que vous vous
dites quand vous tromper nicolas g 30
jamais nicolas tâche est d ailleurs le
seul mais violent là et on marcel
guillaume et violent dans les programmes
des lycées comme toi on peut y arriver
mais saches 1 on est notre héroïne on
voi pas de geste
tu vois ce que je vais dire non j'ai là
dedans je laime sais c'est l'amour de ma
vie en main si il ya le match toulouse
c'est très bien que moi j'y suis et
monogrammes 1 ça veut dire partout en
espagne hall des grands parents
sérieusement victoria il est mieux que
gérard
elle va écouter
et non il est pas non il est pas mieux
que gérard gérard c'est le père de mes
enfants c'est sacré ça et ça parce qu'il
fait lui car tous vos cartes aux dents
par tous car tout le premier toit c'est
imbécile et la nature
c'est la dernière chose qui m'a dit
c'est un imbécile
voilà qui a fait ça fait 20 ans que je
les vois pas nafa qu'entité séparée ou
des 3/4 europe j'aimais les rencontres
ivre morte mois à 6 heures du matin
entre en est sortie d'une discothèque 1
donc ton qu'ils m'arrêtent il me dit et
est ce que tu es un espagnol clair à
temps il est également deuxième longue
alors
il n'est dit hey tu vas une mairie garde
vraiment sur moi j'étais un petit peu
bonne puisque comme on est quand on a
bien maintenant on a bien bien dense et
bien bu et la peau du ventre bien tendue
quoi donc imedi tapera quand ça va dit
donc et stages massacre a dit si tu es
plus tu vas pas le pas fraîche un peu
plus cher que des marques qui est il des
résidents des rires c'est parce que je
me dis oui je suis marqué tellement
jerry brown voilà et tout de suite après
j'ai commencé à monter les escaliers
pour une poule très bien très bien et
j'étais ravi du hockey les bonnes
réponses j'étais ravi des mois d'après
ce que j'ai pas rentrer dans ce truc en
gros si vous êtes un nom n'a plus jamais
revu à retourner jamais
non
mais on
va faire ça je vis a plus jamais a
beaucoup
[Musique]
d'amis
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
vous levez le matin j'ai une sale gueule
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
qu'est-ce que je suis belle qu'est ce
que vous vous dites quand vous venez
comme ça sur un plateau de télé
j'ai envie de faire pipi venez on fait
pipi lé
nom il est tard on s'en faut
moi j'ai envie de rachat garanti est bon
je tourne on
a chacun poteau venait bien va pisser
non alors regardez pas ça va me bloquer
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
vous concentrez pour jouer
sinon je vais tout donner
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
revoyez votre parcours
[ __ ]
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
êtes énervé
j'ai envie de tout défoncer
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous avez
envie d'abandonner
courage qu'est ce que vous vous dites
quand vous recevez pas de scénario
et ben jambes et mon agent mais qu'est
ce que vous vous dites quand un mec de
demandes de coucher avec lui j'ai dit
non encore appartient à un seul homme
c'est celui que j'ai épousé vous êtes
très fidèle et lui oui qu'est ce que
vous en savez magnéto serge
je suis tout le temps avec donc je vois
pas à quel moment il pourra y avoir
débat l'inquiète pas ne comptez pas
hélas il a trouvé ce qu'il fallait à la
maison
non non non non il ya des choses que je
peux être que lui qu'une ou deux fois ne
peut pas faire par exemple
tiens c'est est ce que tu peux les pas
monter la courbe je peux le faire venez
à connotation minute par minute
chantal goya est ce que vous vous êtes
déjà dit le prochain qui me parle du jeu
de la vérité je les mets une grosse
patate je crois que le prochain je vais
le faire mais comment tu as vécu ce jeu
de la vérité
que j'ai fait c'est si longtemps j'ai
inventé reality show comme c'est vrai
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit si je
retrouve cette [ __ ] d'institutrice je
lui défonce la gueule est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit bon j'aime pas les enfants
mais tant pis non non je les adore est
ce que vous êtes déjà dit il boit
d'accord mais bon il fait de bonnes
chansons quand même il n'est pas
alcoolique jean jacques et moi parce
qu'il aime le bon vin mais il voit
jamais le matin jamais à midi et si je
dîne avec une soirée boit pas génial
trimestriels c'est incroyable vous êtes
déjà d'y aller après tout mon mac est en
prison
non est au bout de ma rue en plus vous
êtes déjà dit il est quand même bien
gaulée le capitaine flam kivu non le
vrai
que c'est moi
vous êtes déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lycée trop ça fait quand même quelques
ya pas de mathématiques services privés
j'ai déjà dit chanteuse sait peut-être
pas mon truc finalement
ça l'ex fois parce que saisissent pas
parti pour être chanteuse doit passer
maintenant mais je sais moi même parce
que j'aimerais chanter un peu mieux
vous êtes déjà dit j'ai envie de mourir
là
oui je peux mourir mais mara grandes
antilles c'est qu'est ce qu'on va faire
de moi parce qu'il change son nom ce
matin se met à l'essai dès qu'on savait
pas mettre que tout le monde me disait
maurice qu'on va la lettre et c'était
une horreur j'ai déjà dit allez hop ma
grosse au régime oui oui quand parce
qu'il ya trois ans j'ai réussi j'ai
essayé une robe et la vendeuse elle m'a
dit vous inquiétez pas quand vous aurez
fait votre bébé ça ira là-bas vous ira
mieux mais non c'est mon bide alors donc
j'exhorte allons rentrer dare midi mais
décontracté vous vous êtes déjà dit et
si je me faisais refaire les seins non
non pas du tout ils vont très bien au
moins un essai
non non je ne vais pas kiffer palosanto
mois ils vont bien
vous êtes déjà dit [ __ ] mais qu'est ce
que je fous au queen à trois heures du
matin avec tous ces connards en train de
chanter ma passion pas tous ces connards
mais des fois je me dis il est 4 heures
du matin j'ai toujours pas chanter ils
sont tous comme des fous je suis payé
une balle je donne n'est pas là je
commence à m'endormir va voir ça va être
catastrophique
et maintenant j'ai la pêche qu'ils font
pas ballon à trente deux ans à vous ça
vous fait pas flipper ça non pas du tout
s'est massé non ça veut dire que je suis
leur père de leur enfant c'est ça me
fait un beau cadeau mais tu nous as vu
tout à l'heure weir marché
qu'est ce que vous vous dites quand vous
voyez à l'écran
dieu que je suis moche pendant très
longtemps je me suis pas aimé ah ouais
ouais là après j'ai commencé à m'aimer
avec la barbe et la géologie la couvée
pour un film mais et donc je continue à
ne plus aimer du tout bon sens vous
n'êtes pas mal on me l'a dit après oui
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
venez sur un plateau de télé
si je veux vraiment être franc je dis
merde je suis pas à l'aise ah oui là ça
va vous êtes gentils avec vous on peut
être que gentil que celui que je fasse
ed orange nrj refuse ouais c'est vrai on
voit pas souvent je crois que c'est même
la première fois que vous venez ici
c'était vraiment pour lui c'est gentil
merci pour moi
j'ai dit je serai prêt
qu'est ce qui vous dit quand vous vous
levez le matin
je crois je pense tout de suite à manger
je me lève avec la fin
et je me couche avec la soif d'ailleurs
ses terriers
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
regarder dans un miroir
ça ressemble un peu à une première
question c'est vrai oui ça
je me suis dit septième édition
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
seul chez vous le soir devant un miroir
ou pas n'ont pas de miroir
à vrai dire je suis pas souvent sur le
soir vous pouvez pas être seule salle
j'ai du mal à être seul arrêt en général
chez avec une femme quand même et donc
si elle est pas là je sors un oui on
dirait qu'il ya bien un moment où je
rentre oui
on en revient à votre question 18,6 on
ne laisse rien parce que je suis mort de
fatigue et je dors qu'est ce que vous
dites quand vous voyez votre parcours
c'est ce sont des sentiments mélangés
mais comme je suis quand même quelqu'un
ou très reconnaissant dans la vie je me
dis que j'ai eu beaucoup de chance que
je suis un privilégié et que
j'aime tellement la vie j'aimerais bien
la recommencer le double
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous êtes
énervé
quand je suis énervé je dis d'aidé j'ai
dit des gros mots aux brésiliens et
pourtant les pareilles on y roule à
aller d'accord
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous avez
envie d'abandonner ce métier
j'ai jamais eu envie dans ce métier
jamais jamais le métier me ment jusqu'à
la mort qu'est ce que vous dites quand
vous regarder le journal télévisé mon
dieu ouais qu'est ce que vous dites
quand vous ne recevez pas de scénario
pas de nouvelle bonne nouvelle
ça réflexe de paresseux
qu'est ce que vous dites qu envoyer une
actrice qui veut coucher avec vous
qu'est ce que je dis je dis oui
oui enfin bon
qu'est ce que vous dites que vous n'avez
pas confiance en vos
la seule chance que je me dis
c'est c'est un souvenir de mon
grand-père son son et nord qui m'a dit
tu réussiras là j'ai pas confiance en
moi je me suis souvenu de ça et je crois
qu'il m'a il a porté cet ultime phrase
de cette son existence m'a toujours
conforté dans et d'un optimisme
caractérisée sur sûrement devenir ouais
qu'est ce que vous dites quand on vous
dit que vous n'êtes pas drôle
ça m'énerve
mais je reconnais a acquis qu'on ne peut
trouver drôle ouais je ne dirais pas que
c'est un con
même si je le pense un peu des fois
mais en tout cas je vous dirai pas
qu'est ce que vous dites quand vous
n'avez rien à vous dire
moi je ferme ma gueule
alors est ce que vous êtes déjà dit mais
qu'est ce que je fous à parler de ma
chatte là depuis une heure maintenant
parce que j'ai pas encore joué a donc
j'applique mardi donc on se reverra pour
en parler d'accord et si vous êtes déjà
dit si armande altaï est arrivé je vais
y arriver
non parce que je pense que toutes les
femmes qui sont concernés par par la
cause féminine et par qui sont touchés
par tout ce qu'on peut voir dans le
monde encore aujourd'hui dès l'instant
où il ya une vraie envie une âme je
pense que on peut on peut le jouer ce
même si un vrai travail de comédienne
c'est surtout un texte qui est mis en
avant là d'un talent donc donc voilà
elle s'était déjà dit les moches mais
bon il est producteur
c'est pas le genre de choses que je me
dis non non non si vous êtes déjà dit
lui sait où il veut quand il veut oui
sauf que la tournée
je vous ai déjà dit tiens ce soir je
joue comme une saucisse oui oui ça m'est
arrivé bas notamment avec avec delon les
premières représentations j'étais
tellement impressionné de me retrouver
sur scène au marigny avec lui et des
fois j'avais carrément ddd le regarder
je me dis mais qu'est ce que je fous là
et j'avais un peu des absences wayne là
je sortais en scène pas très contente de
moi oui si vous êtes déjà dit elle est
trop bien gaulée vahina giocante c'est
dégueulasse non j'aime les belles femmes
ouais j'aime les belles femmes à elle
est excessive mont joli ouais
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit justement
avec une fille ça doit être pas mal oui
mais alors où le
nevada et ben alors j'aime les hommes
je vous ai déjà dit non 5 dans un seul
lycée
je me suis pas dit ça parce que je ne me
suis jamais retrouvé dans ce genre de
situation je vous ai déjà dit
aujourd'hui la france demain le monde
quand j'étais petit et que j'avais plein
de plaindre alors les aime dans ma tête
oui certainement maintenant c'est fini
maintenant j'ai envie de me faire
plaisir et j'ai envie de jouer des rôles
qui me qui me plaisent dans lequel je
m'éclate et voilà c'est ma première
vraie raison mais si vous êtes déjà dit
j'ai envie de mourir oui l'a longtemps
pas spécialement
aux belles heures
parce que vous êtes déjà dit et si je
faisais de la ferme célébrités de
l'année prochaine non peut-être dans dix
ans je vous tiendrais pas le même
discours mais pour l'instant non est ce
que vous êtes déjà dit allez hop au
régime ma grosse oui
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit je tuerai
pour ce rôle non est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit mais qu'est ce que l'être
puisque mois nicole kidman
nom pareil je trouve que c'est une
actrice sublime qui est en plus
magnifiquement belle et qu'elle est
intelligente donc non je peux avoir de
l'admiration pour ce genre de femme est
ce que vous êtes déjà dit elle aussi
juste un porno personnes le saura
non non elle si vous êtes déjà dit et si
je prenais des cours de comédie pour un
porno jouer
ben justement manger je me suis
longtemps considéré et puis même encore
maintenant d'ailleurs comme une sorte
d'arrivistes dans ce métier parce qu'il
ya tellement de gens qui ont fait le
conservatoire avait des cours de théâtre
etc moi je suis arrivé par les sites
comme on m'a prise parce que je
ressemblais aux personnages qui étaient
décrits dans la bible et donc voilà au
fur et à mesure j'ai appris à force de
tournage etc et une fois je me suis dit
enfin là plusieurs reprises mais bon une
fois qui m'a marqué je me dis bon
visiblement tu as quelque chose à faire
là dedans tu as un peu de chance parce
qu'il faut un peu de chance si tout ça
s'en va il faudrait peut-être que tu es
un peu de technique donc j'ai voulu
prendre des cours de théâtre est pour
moi plus forte de cela je suis retourné
sur un plateau avec un réalisateur avec
qui j'avais déjà travaillé et on a
commencéà action j'ai commencé à faire
ma scène il a hurlé coupez une voir et
me dit mais qu'est ce que tu fais jimena
parce qu'au cours m'a dit je dis bon
allez je vais arrêter les concédants
votre truc quoi mais j'apprends et puis
je vois là c'est à l'instant vous fait à
l'instinct l'instant est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit si je me faisais refaire
les seins pas encore non est ce que vous
êtes déjà dit tiens il est plus beau au
cinéma lui voit la télé way georges la
célébrité abonnez vous il m'était
impossible